las tropas rusas abandonaron jerson pero
en la miseria se ha quedado los
habitantes de la región sureña de
Ucrania deben convivir con las carencias
provocadas por el conflicto viviendo sin
electricidad insumos médicos y ni
siquiera agua potable los ciudadanos
acuden al río niper para recargar
botellas a pesar de que esa agua no es
apta para consumo
ya han pasado cinco días sin agua y una
semana sin electricidad sabía que podía
pasar así que guarde un poco de agua
para las reservas
la situación ha sido debatida en la
asamblea de Naciones Unidas los miembros
han votado para que Moscú sea
responsabilice de la reparación de los
daños
el resultado de la votación es el
siguiente 94 a favor 14 en contra y 73
abstenciones
la resolución sostiene que Rusia debe
asumir consecuencias jurídicas por actos
internacionalmente ilícitos e insta a
los Estados miembros a colaborar con
Ucrania en la creación de un registro de
pruebas y reclamos
es una reafirmación de la necesidad de
un mecanismo concreto para la
reparaciones que dará vida a esta
proclamación es un llamado para que los
estados miembros se unan y construyan
una infraestructura internacional
legítima para hacer frente a las
consecuencias de la agresión rusa contra
Ucrania
el delegado ruso en Naciones Unidas
acusó que la propuesta es legalmente en
una y denunció a occidente de prolongar
y agravar el conflicto con dinero ruso